um so what anime you flogs watching
well they know what we're watching what
are you what are you watching we never
got to that
what's your favorite anime uh uh uh
um hang on which one of those sentences
am i okay what's your favorite anime
vocano
nice that's high five that's good taste
that's a really that's a really good
taste
why are you on a show called trash taste
but you had great taste i dubbed bikana
well i was when i lived in hong kong one
of my jobs there was i was a dubba so we
dubbed anime
well you're the honk one of the hong
kong voices back
yes what the there was a mate one of the
main kids
young had some guy friel or something
with his name uh real that sounds really
familiar one of those kids
no it wasn't scar boy jacuzzi young
handsome not jacuzzi
he was one of the main kids pharaoh yes
okay hero i'm firo
i'm the old russian man who was doing
all the reincarnations
really scary
um we did the english dubs for animex
so like say you're in hong kong or
singapore or something you can watch out
of max in three languages
japanese yeah local language so like
cantonese or english
so that would be the english dubs for
asia on anime yeah so that wouldn't be
the english dub that played
on the dvd in america no yeah it's
amazing going to conventions and talking
to american dubbers
because they're like yeah one episode
would take about five weeks to dub it
we were like we did six episodes a day
so i was um i was uh tomozo in chibi
marukochan
really i was nezumi otoko in uh
it was [ __ ] insane i was grell in
black butler you're a ghrelin black
butler
i'm grill a bloody girl
if for chinese listeners in uh pleasant
goat and big big wolf i was the wolf
right you did it in chinese no we dubbed
into english
oh it's chinese big time in china
all right um we did tons of it in uh we
did gundam age
i was the um flirty dude in gundam age i
can't remember his name
gundam sangokuden you must have already
been bashing these out yeah jesus christ
[ __ ] i did i just turn up you do
you do you show up what is it all right
the thing okay
all right let's knock him out jesus yeah
so you turned did you even know you
who you were playing what the characters
were or did you just turn up and there
was a script there
and you just had to read normally at the
start of the series we get to do a
little bit of research
right and we get told okay here's
approximately what happens in the story
here's approximately who your character
is
and then we figure out the voice we sit
there with the director we figure out
the voice we're going to do
no no no audition process oh audition
was to get hired by the studio
right so you've been hired and now you
are good enough to do it
yeah yeah um but then we did like in
azuma 11 right
yeah because there's so many characters
in that show yeah right everybody has
like 100 characters
so you kind of you run out of voices
right the soccer teams because they
rotate through
your team every few episodes you just
your team from three episodes ago
starts their voices become the new
team's voice you're like forced
everyone's forced to be mel brooks
basically it's just like let's just do a
hundred voices
[Music]
that was a great job but that was wiped
out the financial crisis you see oh geez
so i had a killer life before then
stop man voice actor act was dope i
can't believe you're animated
you know
yeah you know omni productions oh they
have
the funniest transformers dub you have
yes really
that's what they're notorious for
because this transformers dub is [ __ ]
awful is this the same company that
dubbed dragon ball z movies
and like i think there is it might be
but yeah omni how many times it's like
yeah that was what they were talking
about
like twitter accounts dedicated to
posting clips from it out of context
what's happened to the headmasters can't
they fight without chrome dome
so we i just showed the boys some of the
transformers dubs yeah and um
it's hilarious at the company
let the quality actually go up you know
i don't know depends on what you think
okay
okay listen when i'm doing voice acting
right i know when i'm in a project
there's garbage
cause you're a voice actor too yes yes i
know when i'm in something that i'm like
this is not good on the resume okay you
know what i mean you're right
right did you did you get that feeling
when you're doing any of these dumps or
you're like this is like
this is okay all this is like no i don't
think this is good or you just like it
should work
well you know it's like
maybe sometimes but um you got to do
what you got to do i mean i guess the
fact that we just found out that you
yeah it used to be an anime dog voice
like to say something right yeah but
like
uh look there's dubbing and there's
dubbing there's kind of stuff that you
get sent to doing it some you know
commercial thing and you know yeah the
script is written in broken english
and you're just like no you just you
just record okay and you just do it and
then there's
shows like black butler which were
actual shows right right
so there's dubbing in the stomach tell
me about your um voice acting life
just started when i was uh oh my god how
old was i
15. oh my smokes like my room though
like just doing it for fun because i
loved it
like just doing like fan dubs yeah just
doing like anything and then
went to uh started doing that for a
while got better equipment
had zero training for a while and they
managed to get some
roles like very luckily um oh my god one
of the most embarrassing ones is that a
voice like
i couldn't do this now i think go you
know what i want to say you're going to
[ __ ]
love this so i voiced a nigerian oh dear
you
can't do that yeah so what happened was
is that
again i was like i was like 17 when i
did this it was like age of empires it's
like
i'm sure you know that game yeah they
literally were doing a competition where
i was like
you can voice in the game i was like
fantastic and so they
were big right yeah so they wanted
nigerian accents
and so i i quickly open up google tap go
to youtube
nigerian accent example listen to some
guy who's nigerian speak and i was like
i'm pretty sure i can get close to this
submitted an audition didn't think
anything of it
later at the light yeah so um yeah we
use your lines in the game and i'm like
can i re-record them like no no they're
in the game
the game came out yesterday it's out now
i'm like
what that's amazing but i didn't like
sign any contracts or anything so i
don't know if like
just did you get paid for it uh they
paid me like 200 bucks i'm like thanks
pat me on the back like get him out of
here right
he's gonna say that's called getting it
done yeah yeah right
yeah yeah but like it was like so long
in between you know when i said you know
actually
that's totally cool can they just use
your voice without you signing
it's a competition i'm pretty sure when
you send in the competition there you
know
the fine print probably says something
right yeah that's amazing so you got
into league of legends as a nigerian
uh sorry sorry
archer in some dlc that like never
appears and my mate is obsessed with age
of empires right
wow he just messaged me one day he's
like i think i found you
and he sends me an unlisted youtube clip
and it's like
you know cause you know age of empires
when you're moving around the world it's
like a dark circle that comes visible
and there's the nigerian archer walks in
and he's like hello
welcome pretty village it's literally
like
the ugandan knuckles yeah yeah yeah and
you know i've shown clips of it before
because i just think it's so [ __ ]
embarrassing and stupid
that's not pc there's no way you could
get away with that today yeah yeah
it's as questionable it was but even in
like 2015 that was that there was like
still no problem with that right
[Music]
when i first did my um like actor
registry stuff in australia you have to
list
accents you can do right and i went
through the ones i think just [ __ ]
yeah but then it comes over
like korean yeah just do an
impersonation of my taekwondo master
tick
japanese ah just do it personally for my
friend yuji tick yeah yeah
languages i would never ever ever need
to freaking realize
like so i was doing that and then yeah
just came into a thing and started doing
classes got workshops got more
experience did professional work in
london for a while it's pretty yeah
london yeah so now are you voice acting
here
uh i have done some things here uh i
thought that we talked about the one
thing we did i can't talk about yet so
yeah yeah connor and i did something
recently but we can't talk about it
i don't think it's been recently i
remember you guys saw it it was ages ago
but it still hasn't been released yeah
so really
that happens a lot yeah i shot a thing
in 2016 that came out like a few weeks
you just i mean what
i mean i feel like what you do is you
just record these things and then it's a
pleasant surprise like two three years
forget about when it comes out it's like
oh yeah i did that
yeah yeah oh god i want to read you all
my lines oh
[ __ ] i sucked let's hope the world
hasn't changed around you too much in
the time yeah i hope not not breaking
anything hey guys
it's my newest uh nigerian role
i recorded that seven years ago i hope
you like it
today i'm the voice of it radio network
where an interviewing
voice actor connor did you did you have
to do like an afrikaans accent or did
you have to like ever put on an accent
for any of the animated voices you had
to do
all the time all the time all the time
yeah because i can't really imagine like
an australian accent no the problem with
accents is that you always think you're
better at doing them than you actually
are yeah yeah because you know even if
you're very good and native will be able
to pick it apart
and they'll be like yeah because when i
did the when i did the i did a
voice for pop team epic but like the
character was um
american american it was the mayor of
new york right
in the story julia yeah
it was literally the mayor of new york
and i was like and i said to the
director i was in japanese i was like so
do i have to like do it in an american
accent like i can do an american accent
but it's not
great like i'm just letting you know and
he's like no i just [ __ ] say it hey
i'm like all right sorry because i'm
dead
so i was like so i was like okay i need
to see like how far the limit is right
because usually
they don't take the first take right so
i i can just kind of test the limits to
see like
how far i can go before i have to
eventually redo it again so my first
take was dead i was like
i'm the mayor of new york and uh yeah
welcome everybody
and they [ __ ] took it they don't know
yeah because they don't know they were
like yeah that sounded really new york
i'm like oh
wow no no no no no